if you were to borrow money for
different amounts of time you can
imagine the person lending you the money
might charge you a different annual
interest rate depending on with the
perceived risk of having the money out
there for that amount of time and the
same thing is true when people lend
money to the federal government so when
you think about US Treasuries and US
Treasuries that have different maturity
and the maturity just means when is the
government going to pay you back you
could imagine that their different
interest rates or there's different
yields to maturity on that debt so if we
were to plot it so let's say that and
I'm just going to simplify here let's
say that there's some Treasury debt
that's maturing in one month and if you
look at the price that you would have to
pay for that debt versus the amount of
money that the Treasury is going to pay
you when it matures you see that the
yield there is let's say it is 1% let's
say for Treasuries that are maturing in
three months in three months the yield
is 1.5 percent let's say the Treasuries
that are maturing in I'll just pick some
maturity dates here let's say in one
year in one year the yield is 3% 3%
let's do a couple more let's say in 10
years so if you were to literally you're
essentially borrowing lending money to
the Treasury for 10 years now the annual
interest rate on that let's say it's I
don't know let's say it's three point
five percent and let's throw one up one
more up here let's say if you were to
lend money to the US government for 30
years the yield is running at let's say
it's 4% so here we have different yields
for different maturities and if we
essentially plot this on a graph we get
ourselves a yield curve and it's usually
called the yield curve when people talk
about the yield curve they're talking
about the plot for the US Treasury in
dollars US Treasury bills and bonds you
can have a yield curve really for any
debt instrument for any corporate bonds
or even trip for even government
securities or corporate securities of
other countries but in general when they
talk about the yield curve they're
talking about US Treasuries so let me
draw a yield curve right over here
so on this axis I will put maturity we
scroll down a little bit
maturity and we have a bunch of
different maturities we have one month
let's put squeeze it one month we have
three months and this won't be
completely to scale then we have one
year actually one month and three month
let's just put one month right at the
beginning so one month then three months
is a little bit further out one year
would be right over here one year five
years would be like there five years I
didn't know how I don't have a five
years let's do a ten years so I'll
extend my line over so one year maybe
ten years is over here ten years and
then you have 30 years and I'll just
draw 30 years as far as I can it's not
completely the scale but it's my best
shot and then we plot the yield for
those different maturities so in one
month you have a 1% yield so let me do
it the percentages here so this is 1% 2%
3% 4% so on 1 month
maturity the yield is 1% on three month
maturity the yield is one and a half
percent so maybe it'll be like right
over there on one year maturity the
yield is 3% so you plot one year this is
3% let me write it so this is 3% right
over here this is 1.5% right over there
and the first one right over there was
1% and then at ten years it's three and
a half percent so three and a half is
right over here and we want that to be
ten years so I'm just plotting that
point and in that 30 years it's 4% so 4%
is what we get at 30 years and if we
connect the dots and draw a curve we are
giving ourselves the yield curve we are
giving ourselves the yield curve that
normally well I don't want to make it
look like let me see how well I can draw
it you have a curve that might look
something like that just by looking this
yield curve you see that when you lend
the money when you lend money to the
Treasury for a longer period of time
you're going to get a higher interest
than you would for a shorter period of
time